hello freak [ __ ] yeah you know might
you know my you know my dad actually he
was in a plane crash in his early 20s
and his off San Francisco I need to swim
a couple miles in that water really live
a holy whoa he crashed into the water
yeah yeah most who don't know that it's
oh it's pretty crazy heat and I'm going
to I'm gonna butcher the details but
just you know from growing tech news
yeah exactly
but what happened was he was in the army
and it was right around the time the
Korean War was starting and he was there
flying there doing a routine flight or
something and they had to crash-land in
the ocean whoa and it was getting night
and I I believed I believe the pilot
died and I could be wrong I know the
pilot died but other guy he was with
survived so him and him and his other
guy they were swimming to shore and they
got split up because was getting dark at
night whoa and so the now they're
swimming alone and anyone who knows you
know San Francisco is total yeah yeah
definitely definitely jazz water dump
dump dump dump dump that's what they
breed yeah early yeah great whites breed
in Northern California there's like a
nesting ground up there now [ __ ] now
where you want to crash a plane they're
not when you want to swim from Alcatraz
five times either in your underwear I
know that's great yeah I guess I've
heard of that race yeah but yeah that's
crazy dunno yeah Wow
so you down a swim two miles yeah some
like that need more I could have been
more I mean [ __ ] but it was a long I'm
good for a couple hundred yards yes and
we do not even I start looking for a log
to hang on to I think I think your dad
has property in Oregon or a house or
something does he not that I know we got
a ranch up in Northern California's I
transferred for a long time up in east
of each of reading okay okay now it's in
your and a bernie is and that sort of
area okay and then maybe late like link
Shasta sore area and I think I think we
have a big sawmill yeah
right where I live where Howser I think
he this could be wrong I think he worked
there your dad worked at the warehouse
or sawmill I don't know I mean I think I
know that look there's a lot of I've
heard crime ever crazy things very
crazier let's see if this is crazy
maybe I is on DMT how often you get to
hang out with him well I've been busy
a lot you know is gone for six months in
Australia in China and then before that
I was working on fast and then before
that it was on a movie not as much as
I'd like but he is turn in 87 this year
and that's I'm taking some time off to I
really feel like that's an important
important time in my life to got to be
around him yeah 87 and now that's old
just happens yeah a sudden you're 87 I
did that's almost 90 I didn't know
doesn't feel like Clint Eastwood would
be almost 90 yeah I know ii thought 70
it's just strange
Wow he was just um so he had you when he
was like in his 50th damn son yeah it's
getting shut down yo I got a I have a
sister I have a sister is 19 so I just
turned 20 no wow he was getting it done
he's in their 60s yeah slinging it in
the fifties ha ha ha whoo I get it yeah
yeah so he was married to that girl who
was a newscaster or something right and
they did a reality show
well he did she did a reality show yeah
that wasn't it wasn't he didn't do it at
all it was in no episodes at all well i
yeah ii she might have gotten him into
my force into an episode yeah that was
going on I was like huh this one ain't
gonna work no I wasn't his it wasn't it
was he married to the who is the woman
in icon drew Locke yeah every which way
but yeah yeah never never married oh
they weren't now carries she sued the
[ __ ] out of him though when he broke up
with her oh that was like a crazy story
that he was like blocking her film
projects he was trying to claim that it
was like one yeah I don't think he has
time to deal with that yeah it was kind
of right well she had got
some sort of a deal when they broke up
to do like some film projects was like
part of like the you know separation
deal yeah and she was claiming that he
was somehow another blocking them if I
remember the story correctly well
nothing like a woman school you that he
did he worked at the pulp mill oh well
boy wait but that's why you're in this
on Wikipedia yeah I think he did maybe
my I'll ask him
Oh real bro it's on the internet it's
got to be real I think he did hey look I
don't know if you know about Wikipedia
but this is why I know it's real because
anyone can enter in information and edit
it right that's crazy it was so so a
hundred percent solid this skill reacted
because why why would anybody put
something that wasn't true I think
Wikipedia still says Brian Collins my
brother really who somebody might have
changed it but I left it there forever
[Applause]
[Music]